yeah then I said just try and push it a
step through guys Christopher is
recovering after a nasty fall at home it
left him with a fractured shoulder and
unable to walk he's been moved from
hospital to this specialist step down
unit to help him get ready for discharge
when you in hand and stuff got a lot
more time to sit with you and to talk
talk with you sometimes sometimes it's
just for a friendly chat
the unit has social care and health
staff it means patients like Christopher
don't have to take up a hospital bed
they're overrun at the moment are seeing
a decline when I've been in hospital as
a patient and it's gone right you know
obviously they haven't got time the
delayed discharge of patients who are
medically fit to go home is still one of
the nhs's biggest challenges but it is
finally making up some ground in other
areas the social care system have
problems have issues just as we do
within the hospital system they have
difficulties with Staffing they have
difficulties with illness and sickness
Etc so they have the same they reflect
the same problems that we do which is
why working together is a solution to
this the latest data shows bad occupancy
remains High 19 out of every 20 beds
were occupied in adult General and acute
Hospital Wards last week that's almost
95 percent of dependency but it's down
compared to this time in pre-pandemic
years just over 14 000 beds were
occupied by patients who no longer
needed to be in hospital that's the
second highest on record
and in a sign that pressures are
slightly easing nine percent of
ambulances had to wait more than an hour
to discharge patients that's the lowest
number this winter
any improvements however marginal is
positive news but this doesn't mean the
winter crisis is in any way over things
can change very quickly and the
government and the NHS still has to
contend with ongoing industrial action
from health workers including one day
next month when ambulance workers and
nurses will strike together for the
first time
yes there is still no settlement in
sight and for these striking nurses that
means a long and bitter campaign ahead
it's not just about Faye it's about
patient safety and a good nurse to
Patient ratio
Christopher is looking forward to going
home eventually but until he's ready
he'll stay here it's better for him it's
better for the NHS and it's waiting
patience oh she's Joshi Sky News